welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition so sit back shut
the hell up
because we're going back to a quiet
place with the release of the second
film's trailer Shh
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie and some of the
things that you missed from the trailer
itself there may be heavy spoilers here
so if you want to go into the movie as
blind as possible get it because the
months of the book never mind then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
because we're going to be talking about
as much of the movie as we know so far
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of a
quiet place part two okay so before we
get into the trailer breakdown let's
talk about the movie in general the film
is scheduled to be released on the 20th
of March 2020 in both the US and UK it
was originally slated for May the 15th
however paramount must be confident as
they moved it forward massively this
could also be because the original film
was released on April the 6th and the
studio are trying to keep it more in
line with this the original cast are all
back as well except for John Krasinski
who yeah saddest death of 2018 he is
back in the directing seat though and
though we don't know for definite yet I
do think he will appear in the film in
flashbacks when discussing a sequel that
the creative team stated it feels like
there are a billion places to take a
quiet place sequel for example are there
other families out there there are so
many discarded set pieces to just hiding
out on Word documents on our computer so
yeah there are certainly so many stories
you could tell it just really at the end
of the day who are the characters in
this and what does this situation mean
to that dynamic so it looks like we will
be getting a similar aesthetic to the
original film with Krasinski also
stating it's not like alien our jaws
where the main villain is a thing you're
repeating it's an actual entire set of
rules and the circumstance that the
world has undergone that you can play
with in very different facets so it does
look like the family will still be
remaining as quiet as possible instead
of going all gung-ho on the creatures
they will be traveling to other
locations and interacting with other
people and the movie actually has some
quite big names attached to it now
including Killian Murphy and demon hunt
sue who
set to star on the sequel of definitely
butchered his name anyway Brian Tyree
Henry was originally meant to star in
the film but there were some
announcements that he was replaced in
interviews this year I mean last year
god I feel so weird saying he paid a lot
of lip service to what could be coming
in the movie and said I really think
that what we'll do is we'll see more of
that family continuing to survive and
finding out they're not the only ones
and I think that we're also going to get
a few answers to the origin of where and
how this whole thing happened but I
think you're gonna see another side of
it more of humanity that survived this
thing in the next story okay now on to
the trailer itself so as you may have
guessed it a quiet place to is a direct
follow-on from the first film when
movies are cool part two they tend to
just be direct follow-ups and a quiet
place part two takes place immediately
after the events of the first film
though we do know that we will be seeing
the outbreak of the invasion from the
perspective of the family initially in
the trailer the mother Evelyn played
once more by Emily Blunt isn't able to
get a signal on the radio it is likely
that the creatures attacked broadcasting
places first as we do know that through
their ear canals they were able to pick
up on frequencies and so on this was how
Regan was able to defeat the monsters
using her bone anchored hearing aid as
they could tap into this frequency and
thus they got a worse headache that I'm
sure a lot of you did this morning
so yeah it's likely that they would have
wiped out radio and TV stations first as
they broadcast the most signals later in
the trailer we do see the son Marcus
being surprised that there's a radio
broadcast so I think this adds a lot of
weight to the theory that it is widely
known that these were the first elements
of society to be targeted we also see
the family pastor fatherly which again
ties back to my theory that he will be
in the movie during these sections the
bus approaches them and as Evelyn
reverses we can slowly see a monster
climbing out before it cuts to the
Paramount logo next up we see the farm
on fire which is obviously why the
family had to go out to other
communities however not everyone seems
that welcoming and they spring a bottle
trap and then find themselves in a
sniper scope I do want to say that this
was set for the monsters and not for
people which we'll get into in just a
bit
there are some theories floating about
that people may be just as bad as the
creatures we don't know how the barn was
set on fire so it could be possible that
looters tried to invade it or the finale
in the first film ended up causing the
blaze I'm leaving more towards the
latter as I can see people venturing how
much which cemented by this trap the
barn is light is shown in the trailer
from the perspective of Marcus so yeah
it looks like whatever causes this blaze
will be part of the opening anyway the
aesthetic of the trailer it reminded me
massively of the Last of Us and I love
how they're going with the motif that
humans don't trust each other anymore
because of how bare-bones everything is
if everyday was a fight for survival you
would probably put your best interest
first so it would be difficult to form
bonds we also see the newborn baby as
well as a bandage around Evelyn's foot
which is from when she stood on a nail
in the last movie they are likely
looking for a new home and we can see
them carrying in the box that the baby
was kept in as well as the oxygen tank
that was used to hide it from the
monsters in case it began crying when
running they come face to face with
Killian Murphy who saves them so the
trap from earlier was probably set for
the monsters as he could have easily
shot them at this moment though yeah
this would have drawn attention and so
on you've got you've got to choose your
battles in this world though he will
likely only have self interest it is
possible that people are still genuinely
good and just want to help each other he
says that people are bad but Evelyn kind
of rebuff this and says that there's
people worth saving and it's slightly
that this will be a road trip to rally
communities together under one common
cause kill you Murphy he does say that
the people that are left on with saving
and this kind of hints at the journey
that he's been through we also see some
of the invasion from his perspective and
he's likely seen the ugly side of
humanity which is why the beacon of
Evelyn and the rest of the family is so
important to him his character also
lives in a furnace which is likely
soundproofed and he's probably lived a
very isolated life we are clearly
getting a lot of the invasion from his
point of view including a look at him
and demons character saving some
children though they could have ended up
just leaving them which i think will be
the case as again
everyone is just out for themselves now
as for the overall meaning of the film
and its themes I think this will
massively juxtapose the first entry in
our original film breakdown we did say
that the monsters were sort of a
metaphor for censorship and how because
of the world around them the Abbott's
were scared to talk or really express
themselves in any meaningful way this
led the daughter Reagan to believe that
her father didn't love her which he did
and so on yeah there was a lot of things
going on here language wise even the
family themselves just lived in their
own corner of the world and from the
campfire scene we do know that there
were other communities around them from
the fires that we saw lighting up they
still just kept themselves to themselves
though which again ties back to
censorship and an inability to express
themselves and so on it may be a bit of
a reach but that's just how I always
took the film the second film seems a
lot more about opening yourself up
though and reaching out to other people
which of course will be seen in them
traveling to other places and people
around the area overall the trailer
looks like the perfect continuation on
the first movie and I can't wait to see
what happens in the film when it drops
in March it's got an amazing atmosphere
to it and I think there's probably more
dialog in this trailer than there was in
the original movie which is absolutely
crazy this is one of my most anticipated
movies of the air and I really can't
wait to see what happens in it also I
haven't mentioned it so far but happy
New Year and thank you everyone for your
support
over the last one I really I still can't
believe how much the channel has grown
and it's just incredible to me so thank
you for all your support I tell you if
you'd seen the state of me last night it
was a miracle that this video got out I
was I was like well they're monsters
lashing out where they sound you know
anyway thanks again for all your support
and all the best for 2020 now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer and if you're hyped for the
movie comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up in silence and make
sure you check out our full breakdown of
this week's big release you season 2
which would be linked at the end we go
over everything you need to know about
the show and give our theories on the
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below
we drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else and
that's the best place to be it's free to
join and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
also giving away a free copy of Joker
which was one of our favorite movies of
last year and all you have to do to be
in with the chance of winning it's like
the video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
trailer in the comment section below the
one it's going to be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you